[موسيقى]
هذه قصه حرب لم تنتقل نفسها اسمنت حرب
بدات قبل 40 عاما ولما يعلن رسميا عنها
الحرب بين ايران من جهه
والولايات المتحده واسرائيل من جهه اخرى
تعد حربا ايديولوجيه واستراتيجيه في ان
معا
ذ الكراهيه وان حدث يوما وانطلقت شرارتها
فسوف تشتعل النيران في الشرق الاوسط
باكمله وربما تتطور الى صراع عالمي جديد
وكيف نفهم هذه العوده المحتمله الى دوامه
العنف علينا ان نعود بالزمن الى الوراء
لنفكك خيوطا ماساه المتشابكه
وانا ابحث عن الحقائق المتواليه خلف
العقائد والثوابت
ونرويه هذه الحكايه
الاول من شباط فبراير عام 1979
رحله جويه من باريس الى طهران حملت معها
بدايه لتاريخ جديد تاريخي هذه الحرب
هذا هو ايه الله الخميني
ويستعد لتغيير تاريخ ايران بشكل جذري
[موسيقى]
من الناحيه التاريخيه جسد ايه الله
الخميني معارضه الشعب للشاه الامبراطور
القوي الذي حكم ايران لما يقرب من 40 عاما
بعد اكثر من 14 عاما في المنفى عاد ايه
الله اخيرا الى الوطن لخوض المعركه
الحاسمه الى جانب شعبه حقبه جديده كانت
على وشك ان تبدا في الشرق الاوسط
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
انتفاضه في عام
1978 خرج مئات الالاف من الايرانيين الى
الشوارع يتحدون حاكمهم
ريجيم في شهر
ديكتاتوريه
عسكريه
المال وظلم الشعب وانما على كافه مستويات
السلطه
[موسيقى]
ومثل هذا الفساد يكون دافعا جيدا للغايه
لتشجيع ايا كان على معارضته اي نظام
واطلاق يد الخبراء الغربيين في بلادهم وقد
اعتبروه نظام غير عادلا وفاسدا فشل في
تلبيه ابسط الاحتياجات الاساسيه لشعبه
[موسيقى]
كانت هناك دولتان تجسدان الامبرياليه التي
اذانها المتظاهرون دولتان دعمتان نظام
الشاه هما الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
[موسيقى]
دومين صعوبه بمكان تخيل ان هذين البلدين
كان اقرب الحلفاء الى ايران
ممتازه عاش العديد من الاسرائيليين في
ايران واسعد البلاد في العديد من المجالات
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه الينا يمكننا القول ان ايران كانت
اهم شريك لنا بعد الولايات المتحده من حيث
المصالح الاقتصاديه وقد قمنا ببعض
المشاريع الضخمه معهم
الماضي قدمت اسرائيل عروضا كثيره للشاه
كانت الدوله العبريه المعزوله في وسط عالم
عربي يرفض الاعتراف بوجودها تبحث عن شركاء
غير عرب في منطقه ابعد قليلا في الشرق
الاوسط ايران الفارسيه المواليه للغرب
المبنيه على نمط من الاسلام مختلف عن ذاك
السائد في الدول العربيه بارزت حينها
كحليف طبيعي
كثيرا ما كان الايرانيون ياتون الينا من
الصعب تخيل ذلك الان ولكنه كان تعاونا
وثيقا للغايه
[موسيقى]
في ايران عام 77 اي قبل عام من تصاعد
الاحتجاجات كانت مهمته تعزيز تعاون
الامنيه بين البلدين
في ذلك الوقت
كانت ايران تدفع لاسرائيل من اجل تزويدها
بالمعدات والمعرفه في مجالات فائقه
الحساسيه
نتيجه نتيجه
ايران حجر الزاويه لنفودها في المنطقه
لذلك تم تصميم الدرجه عاليه من التعاون
العسكري بهدف ابقاء طهران ضمن المعسكر
الغربي
كانت تلك فتره الحرب البارده وكانت ايران
الساحه الرئيسيه للمنافسه بين الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد السوفيتي
التشهد بالطبع هو الجانب الامريكيه لان
العناصر اليثاريه في ايران والمدعومه من
الاتحاد السوفيتي كانت ضد نظامه
انه في عام 77 78 كان اعظم حديثي لايران
هما امريكا واسرائيل
[موسيقى]
تحت حكم الشاه شريكا لا يقدر بثمن وكانت
الحجر الاساسي في لعبه الشرق الاوسط
الكبرى لكن لا اسرائيل ولا امريكا ادركت
مدى وقوه المعارضه التي كان مقدرا لها ان
تسود
عندما كنت اتحدث الى جنرال كانوا يقولون
لي انظر هذه اشبه بالحصبه نشاهد المظاهرات
في الوقت الحالي هذا هو الوضع لقد طلب
منها الشاه بصفته القاعده العسكريه نتدبر
امرها حسنا نحن نقوم بذلك
[موسيقى]
او العسكريين مهتمين بالوضع القائم واراده
تبرير ايمانهم بشهر بان الاموره كانت تسير
على ما يرام وانها ستستمر على تلك الحال
اذا كان اولئك هم الاشخاص الذين تعاملنا
معهم اشخاص لم يكونوا على درايه جيده وما
كانوا ليقدم لنا انباء عن سيئه
دار والله
[تصفيق]
من قبل نظام يواجه مثل هذه الانتفاضه
القويه والحازمه يتجه بالبلاد نحو الماساه
دماء غزيره غطت شوارع طهران في تلك الجمعه
السوداء بعد ما فتحت قوات الجيش نيرانها
على المحتاجين بحسب المصادر الرسميه سقط
87 قتيلا لكن تقديرات المعارضه اكدت ان
عدد القتلى تجاوز ال 4000 لقد كشف النظام
عن وجهه الحقيقي
اذكروا اني كنت استحم في ذلك الصباح بعد
يوم الجمعه الاسود كان الجو باردا وبدا ان
ما نتعامل معه كان حربا بين الشاه وشعبه
وبدى لنا ان الشها لن يفوز واننا سوف
نتعامل مع مستقبل في ايران مختلف عن ما
كنا نعرفه في الماضي
الى اهداف وبداوا في مغادره البلاد هاجم
المتظاهرون المقاهي والمطاعم والبنوك ودور
السينما وهي رموز الغربيه للحداثه
المرتبطه بالقبضه الخالقه التي راوا ان
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده طوقتها بلادهم
بها
امريكا امريكا
الخطاب اليسري الذي راى ان الامبرياليه هي
التهديد المهيمن وهي تناقض رئيس كما كنا
نسميها في ذلك الوقت والذي يجب حله
القدر ضد الولايات المتحده لكنهم راوا
فيها منزل
[تصفيق]
مره اخرى
ان اسرائيل كانت متواطئه في حرمان
الفلسطينيين من حقهم
[موسيقى]
كان هناك اعتقاد قوي
بان جهاز الشرطه امريكا
تقليد الملكيه وقطع العلاقات مع واشنطن
وتل ابيب ورفض الحداثه على النمط الغربي
اهداف جمعتها سويا معركه واحده
ولكي تنجح الثوره كان لابد لنضال من قائد
شخص يجسد الثوره والنظام
بدات الحركه في اكتساب الزخم وكانت حركه
بحاجه الى قياده وبحاجه الى زعيمه بدا ان
شخص مناسبه
[موسيقى]
وطئت قدماء الخميني ارض ايران وكان
مستعيدا لتوجيه الضربه القاضيه للنظام
الملكي
بعد 10 ايام وبعد 48 ساعه فقط من القتال
في شوارع طهران اكتملت الاطاحه بنظام
الملكي الايراني الذي سيطر عليه الشاه
طيله 37 عاما
[موسيقى]
حققت الثوره انتصارا كاملا واصبح ايه الله
الخميني الزعيم الجديده للبلاد
[موسيقى]
سبونج بوب
مع طرد البعثه الدبلوماسيه الاسرائيليه
وتخريب اجزاء من مقرها كان اعضاء البعثه
البالغ عددهم 33 اخر الاسرائيليين
المتبقين في ايران وكانوا بحاجه الى ايجاد
سبيل للهروب
لم يعد احد منا الى منزله اقبل انتقلنا
الى عناوين مؤقته لكل خمسه او سته منا في
شقه معا وبقينا هناك لمده اسبوع
والبعض كان يحمل جوازات سفره كنا نستعد
لفرار في ذلك الوقت كان الامر صعبا وعدد
قليل جدا من الناس تمكنوا من الخروج الى
الشارع
[موسيقى]
الى فندق هيلتون في وسط طهران حيث كانت
تنتظرهم حافله لتقل لهم الى المطار الذي
يبعد حوالي 17 كيلو مترا 17 كم عبر شوارع
ملتهبه بالثوره كل شيء كان محتمل الحدوث
شيباس الكيلو متر 17 كيلو مترا 10 ملايين
ايرانيه على جانبي الطريق جميعهم يحملون
طماطم وبيض وعلمتني الحافله سائق ورجلان
ايرانيان يحملان بنادق كلاشنكوف تحركت
حافلتنا ظنوا انها تحمل ثوارا فلم يمظروها
بالبيض او الطماطم
واخيرا من الصعود الى الطائره ثم الاقلاع
والنجاه ربما
شاهين ولما ترقص صعدنا الى الطائره في
اداره المحركات
[موسيقى]
بدات الطائره تتحرك ثم توقفت فجاه فتحت
الابواب واقتحم اولئك الثوار مره اخرى
الباب
ذلك كان عدو الاسرائيليين الاكبر ياسر
عرفات زعيم منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه يصل
الى طهران ويتم استقباله كرئيس دوله حقيقي
[موسيقى]
كان عرفات قد اصبح زعيم منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه في عام
1969 وكان طموحها المعلن اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله من قاعدته في لبنان كان
عرفات الى جانب الفدائيين يشن عمليات ضد
الشمال الاسرائيلي الان جاء ليطلب دعم
الخميني الرجل الذي كان يامل بانه سوف
يساعد الفلسطينيين على نيل الاستقلال
دفنت ليه
يبعث برساله قويه الى العالم الاسلامي
باسره من الان فصاعدا سوف تدعم ايران
القضيه الفلسطينيه وتعتبرها صراعا وجودا
بين الاسلام والغرب الامبريالي عرابي دوله
العبريه
[موسيقى]
ثم اتخذ الخميني مبادره مفاجاه بتحويل مقر
البعثه الدبلوماسيه الاسرائيليه الى سفاره
فلسطين كان ذلك اعلان قويا بهذه المبادره
قطع ايه الله كل الصلات مع اسرائيل الدوله
التي لا شرعيه لوجودها في عرف ايران
الجديده بالتالي اصبح كله
بين اسرائيل وايران جزءا من الماضي
[موسيقى]
اعترفت الولايات المتحده بالجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الفتيه لكن في واشنطن كان هناك
بعض القلق بشان النوع العلاقات الممكنه مع
حكام ايران الجدد
داخل الحكومه الامريكيه كانت هناك اراء
متباينه اعتقد البعض ان الخميني كان قوه
متطرفه ورجاليه يصعب علينا التعامل معها
في ايران كدوله يمكننا الاستمرار في
التعايش معها واننا على الرغم من رحيل
الشاه سنحافظ على العلاقات كانت لدينا
سفرتنا هنا
ثم في الرابع من تشرين الثاني نوفمبر
1979 اقتحم مئات الطلاب الاسلاميين
السفاره الامريكيه واحتجزوا 52 دبلوماسيا
كراهان
كان الخميني امام سؤال محوري هل يدعم
هؤلاء الطلاب ويخاطر بتعريض العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده للخطر هل يدعمهم فيبقى
حركتهم تحت سيطرتها
[موسيقى]
هاي هاي
في امريكا
[موسيقى]
وبعد
444 يوما نجحت الوساطه الجزائريه في
الافراج عن الرهائن من خلال تقديم الدعم
للطلاب كان الخميني يمهد للمرحله الثانيه
من الثوره مرحله توطيد النظام الجديد كان
الشرق الاوسط الجديد يتشكل لا شيء سيكون
على حاله هذا مره اخرى كانت طموحات طهران
ومصالحها على مسار تصادمي مع واشنطن وتل
ابيب وكان الصدام الكبير يلوح في الافق
[موسيقى]
في السادس من يونيون وحزيران عام 82 اجتاح
الثمانين الف جندي اسرائيلي الاراضي
اللبنانيه تحت غطاء جوي كثيف يدعمهم 1,300
دبابه
و1500 ناقله جنط لم يكن لبنان الذي مزقته
الحرب الاهليه حتى تلك اللحظه جزءا من
المواجهه الناشئه بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل وايران لكنه تحول الى ساحه
مفتوحه لمعارك اقليميه كان لسوريا وجود
عسكري ونفوذ كبير في شرق البلاد اما في
الجنوب فكانت منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
شديده القوه بعد ما اتخذت من منطقه
الحدوديه قاعده انطلاق عملياتها وشم هجمات
مجاعه لاسرائيل
في خضام هذا الواقع الميداني اطلق التل
ابيب عمليه عسكريه اسميتها سلامه الجليل
ضد مقاتلين منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
بهدف وضع حد للهجمات التي يشنها الفلسطيني
كان لابد من اجبارهم على العوده الى ما
وراء الخط الذي من شانه ان يحمي اسرائيل
من ايرانهم تردد الشائعات عن امتلاكه من
مدفع طويل المدى من طراز
لذلك كان عليهم تراجع مسافه 40 كم او اكثر
من الحدود
في غضون اسبوع تجاوز شارون الاهداف
المعلنه للعمليه بكثير فعلى الرغم من
المقاومه الشرسه التي واجهتها القوات
الاسرائيليه في عدد من المناطق من قبل
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين واللبنانيين من
الاحزاب اليسريه والاسلاميه الا ان حجم
الزحف الاسرائيلي كان ضخما ما مكه نشارا
من الوصول الى مشارف العاصمه بيروت في
غضون اسبوع
بكثير استمر شارون في التقدم اكثر فاكثر
شمالا حتى اقترب من بيروت
[موسيقى]
كان طهران تراقب ما يجري بذهول مع تقدم
القوات الاسرائيليه نحو العاصمه اللبنانيه
كان ميزان القوه في الشرق الاوسط يتغير
بشكل جذري بالنسبه للخميني كان الامر لا
يحتمل التفكير لكن كيف يجب ان يتصرف
دخلت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه في
حرب شامله ضد العراق استمرت الحرب ثمانيه
سنوات واصبحت تعرف باسم الحرب الايرانيه
العراقيه في هذه المرحله لم تتوفر لدى
مؤسس الجمهوريه الاسلاميه موارد كافيه
لفتح جبهه اخرى ضد اسرائيل في لبنان
اخو مين
يبرر فيه هذا القرار قائلا ان الطريق الى
القدس يمر بكربلاء وهو اسلوب ديني للتعبير
عن قرار الاستراتيجيا عميق يعني اطلاع
ايران لدور ما في تحرير القدس ياتي بعد ان
تتمكن من هزيمه صدام حسين والتمهيد الطريق
نحو كربلاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في بيروت كان القصف العنيف ينهمر على غرب
العاصمه حيث لا جاء عرفات ومعظم مقاتليه
[موسيقى]
سوء جزء من المدينه بالارض وقتل الاف
معظمهم من المدنيين
[موسيقى]
في ال 21 من اب اغسطس عام 1982 انتهى
الحصار الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
غادر عرفات لبنان الى تونس مع عشره الاف
من الفدائيين
وسرعان محله محلهم قوه متعدده الجنسيات
مؤلفه بشكل اساسي من جنود امريكيين
وفرنسيين مهمتهم ضمان سلامه العاصمه
اللبنانيه
بالنسبه لشارون ورئيس الوزراء من لحين
بيجن فقد انتهى امر القضيه الفلسطينيه
تماما وصار بامكانهم المضي قدما بتحقيق
هدف اسرائيل السري المتمثل في تغيير وجه
لبنان عبر تنصيب رئيس لبناني موال لها
لبنان الجديد هذا سيكون بلدا قويا والاهم
من ذلك كله سيكون بلدا حليفا لاسرائيل لكن
هذه الخطط ايقظه اللبنانيين بمختلف
الطوائفهم ومن بينهم الشيعه من سكان
الجنوب الذين عانوا بشكل مباشر من الغزو
والاحتلال الاسرائيليين وقرر بعضهم حمل
السلاح والمقاومه
[موسيقى]
في قناعه
سنه 1982
ان اسرائيل عدو
وكنت اناصر القضيه الفلسطينيه
واعتبر اني في هذا الخندق
[موسيقى]
نعيم قاسم كان حينها في التاسعه والعشرين
من عمره مدرسه كيمياء في بيروت وكان رئيسا
الاتحاد الجمعيات التربويه الاسلاميه وهو
منظمه شيعيه
هو الذي يعبر بشكل مباشر عن هذه القناعه
التي نؤمن بها فجمعنا انفسنا واتفقنا عده
حركات اسلاميه ومجموعات اسلاميه كانت
موجوده في لبنان
وذهبنا الى ايران واعلنا استعدادا
ومبايعتنا للامام الخميني ليكونا قائدا
لنا
ووليا للفقيه وهو اعطى المبارك
[موسيقى]
فهذا سيتيح له الاقتراب من اسرائيل
ومحاربتها بشكل افضل من خلالها هؤلاء
الحلفاء الجدد
[موسيقى]
من يفضل ليزر
الثوره في ايران
مناصب عليا بعد اسابيع من الثوره
عام
1982 اجتمع قاده شيعه لبنانيون في مدينه
بعلبك في سهل البقاع الشرقي البلاد لتاسيس
منظمه جديده لمحاربه اسرائيل بدعم من
الحرس الثوري الذي نشا حديثا اطلقت على
نفسها اسم المقاومه الاسلاميه في لبنان
بعد ذلك بثلاث سنوات في عام
1985 اتخذت المنظمه سماح حزب الله رسميا
في البدايه كانت اهدافها في الغالب عمليه
وسريه
بما ان المقاومه كانت ناشئه ولا تريد ان
تنكشف حتى تستطيع ان تمتد وتنتشر وتقوم
باعمالها
ارتقينا ان السريه هي اصل وبالتالي لابد
ان نقوم باعمال تنتج بدل ان نقف مستعرضين
او ان ندرس انفسنا كسياسيين
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
كلمه كان هدف حزب الله في البدايه هو هدف
عسكري مقاومه اسرائيل استعمال السلاح وليس
فقط السلاح كل
الوسائل المتاحه لدفع اسرائيل للانسحاب من
لبنان ولهازيمه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
لمساعده التنظيم الجديد ارسلت ايران بضع
مئات من الحرس الثوري الى البقاع خلال صيف
عام
1982 وكانت هذه القوات جزءا من هيئه
النخبه التي نشات عند ولاده الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه والمكلفه بالدفاع عنها شكل
الحرس الثوري للنظام وهم يعتمرون مباشره
باوامر المرشد الاعلى
ولا الحرس الثوري ولا حتى غير ايران ما ان
تقاتل نيابه عن اللبنانيين والفلسطينيين
في وجه اسرائيل المطلوب هو تقديم الدعم
المطلوب في وقت لم يكن هناك ابدا من يدعم
القوى التحرريه المناهضه لاسرائيل
[موسيقى]
في حين ان هؤلاء الجنود النخبه لم يقاتلوا
في الواقع الا انهم قدموا الاسلحه والمال
والمعرفه كان لحضورهم هذا تاثير في دوله
اخرى كان لجيشها وجود في هذا الجزء من
لبنان سوريا
[موسيقى]
بيبي
تنظيم حزب الله والتحالف مع الاسد
الى الاسد لكسب علاقه معه
لقد ارادوا ان تكون لديهم ادوات تحت
تصرفهم لتهديد اسرائيل مما يعني تهديد
الولايات المتحده
في لبنان
الدوله
في الشرق
ما تجذر ضمن حدود سهل البقاع كان نظام
تحالفات حقيقيا
نشا تنظيم شيعي في الجنوب اللبناني وتطور
تعاونا الدلاحقا الى ظهور محور مؤثر في
الشرق الاوسط هو محور ايران سوريا حزب
الله في تلك اللحظه لم يكن احد على درايه
بظهور هذا التنظيم ولا سيما الامريكيون
والاسرائيليون
[موسيقى]
دير قانون في جنوب لبنان على بعد حوالي 10
كيلو مترات من الحدود الاسرائيليه حوالي
السادسه والنصباحا تغادر سياره بيجو بيضاء
محشوه بالمتفجرات القريه متجهه نحو مدينه
صور
السابعه صباحا الحادي عشر من تشرين الثاني
نوفمبر عام
1982 احمد قصير يقود سيارته على طول
الطريق الرئيسي عبر صور يسرع بدون تردد
ويقذف بنفسه وسيارته في مجمع سكني كبير
كان مقر الحاكم العسكري الاسرائيلي لجنوب
لبنان باكمله قد انهار للتو
مبنى من سبعه طوابق اصبح ركاما
[موسيقى]
91 جنديا اسرائيليا لكم حدفهم ومعهم 15
اسيرا لبنانيا اريل شارون كان في حيره من
امره كيف يمكن لشيء كهذا اي يحدث بعد مرور
اكثر من شهرين على سحق العدو الوحيد
المعروف منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
بجوع قبلني
الاشرف اليوم
بعد ثلاثه اسابيع خلصت لجنه التحقيق الى
انبوبه غاز قديم فجر معلنه ان الحديث كان
عرضيا هذه روايه مذهله للاحداث لم تواجه
باي تشكيك على الصعيد الرسمي مما يؤكد فشل
اجهزه المخابرات الاسرائيليه في معرفه ما
كان يجري في سهل البقاع
[موسيقى]
محدثه جدا
كان يدخل كم
[موسيقى]
اكبر بكثيره عندما بدات في اجراء بعض
الابحاث بشان ما اذا كان معروفا في دوائر
المخابرات عن الشيعه في لبنان شعرت بخيبه
امل كبيره لم اجد اي شيء تقريبا كان هناك
صفر من اوراق العمل بشان هذا الموضوع لم
يكن هناك شيء يذكر في الاقسام الاكاديميه
ايضا مجرد معلومات قليله للغايه
جنبها
اكاديمي اناشيد
[موسيقى]
الفرنسيين غافله مثل ما كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الثالثه والعشرين من تشرين
الاول اكتوبر عام 83 اي بعد عام تقريبا
جاء دورهم ليستهدفهم هجوم مماثل من العنف
غير مسبوق
[موسيقى]
خسر الامريكيون وواحد 241 جنديا وبعد
دقائق تعرض مقر الجيش الفرنسي بمبنى
دراكار لهجوم ثاني اسفر عن مقتل 58 شخصا
ضربه مزدوجه تبنتها حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
والتي يعتقد انها مجرد اسم مستعار للتحالف
بين حزب الله وايران
[موسيقى]
سنافر
انها نجحت في التنصت على اجتماع طلب فيه
صراحه السفير الايراني في سوريا والذي كان
من ابرز مؤسسي حزب الله تنفيذ مثل هذه
العمليه لم تعلن المخابرات الامريكيه هذا
الدليل وكانت مخطئه وكاتبه في الماضي لكن
حقيقه ان ذلك ظهر في كتب اشخاص اعتقد انهم
يتمتعون بصدقيه قويه يعني ان هذا يجب ان
يؤخذ على محمل الجنس في النهايه الادراك
هو الحقيقه لقد تصرفت الولايات المتحده
وفرنسا ودول الاخرى بناءا على تصور ان
الايرانيين كانوا وراء ذلك
[موسيقى]
مع هذا الهجوم الجديد لم يعد من الممكن
تجاهل لحزب الله
بدا وكانه محلي ثم بحلول منتصف
الثمانينيات كان من الواضح ان هناك خطا
للاسلحه والذخائر وكان هناك رجال ياتون من
ايران ورهائن ينقلون من لبنان الى ايران
ودعم سياسي اذا كانت تلك ظاهره مستجدده
[موسيقى]
غرفه غرفه
مسلحه بدون دعم السكان المحليين
بنى الايراني
تصفيه
حزب الله الثانويه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يوما بعد يوم كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يزداد
تبراطا في المستنقع اللبناني في السادس من
حزيران يونيو عام
1985 اي بعد ثلاث سنوات من بدء الاشتياح
انسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي محتفظا بمنطقه
امنيه في الجنوب تمثل 10% من الاراضي
اللبنانيه بقي الجيش الاسرائيلي هناك لمده
15 عاما حتى عام 2000
بالنسبه لاسرائيل شكل هذا الانسحاب الجزئي
الاول هزيمه قاسيه ومهينه اما بالنسبه
لحزب الله فذلك كان نصره الاول اختار
الحزب اللحظه المناسبه ليعلن المسؤوليه عن
تدمير مقر الحاكم الاسرائيلي في سور
الحادي عشر من تشرين الثاني نوفمبر يوم
الهجوم اصبح مناسبه سنويا تحييها المقاومه
تحتميه يوم الشهيد
عندما توفي ايه الله الخميني في حزيران
يونيون عام
1989 كان ارسله اكثر حيويه من اي وقت مضى
ترى الصخت نظريه الحكم الديني الشيعي التي
اسسها الخميني قبل عشر سنوات وقد غيرت
المعركه التي بداها ضد اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده من خلال حزب الله ملامح المشهد في
الشرق الاوسط لكن اذا نظرنا نحو المستقبل
ترى ماذا سيفعل خلفاء الخميني بارثه
[موسيقى]